as a fan of your work
of stage screen movie theaters
television what is coming up for you
after you wrap a post-production on the
next film do you know what you're
looking at in terms of the next year or
two the the post-production for nyle
will take me through to the autumn and
then we'll hopefully we'll release that
I've been writing a small personal film
which is what I shall do next
really yeah you haven't written
something in many many years well the
truth is actually Steve I've written
lots of things but I'd haven't haven't
deemed them deemed them good enough so
I'm a pretty packed bottom drawer but
I've cracked but I've practiced a lot
and so my latest practicing is producing
something I'm beginning to think might
be my next project and that's been borne
out of this this this period of sort of
enforced reflection it's let me do some
things that I haven't had time to do so
I'm looking forward to to that something
on a smaller scale that's right out of
my guts can you share the title or now I
can't right now
hey nice yes up but but when it's ready
I'm gonna arrive at your front door bit
under my tarp and I'll be dressed as
Christopher Nolan that'd be amazing